hello and welcome to the monitor good
morning wake up
it's not as early as you think it is
maybe you overslept maybe you passed out
and is very late and i'm young at you to
maybe think about sobering up and
getting your life back together at any
rate
we're here now so so let's commune
you're with me i'm with you let's talk
about things that are happening this
week let's talk about nbc's last stab at
sitcom relevance or let's talk about one
of my favorite board games that has come
that just came out for the ipad or let's
talk about going to the movies together
the theater the cinema does that sound
good perhaps me and you
jumbo bucket of popcorn
snuggle up during the previews all right
anyway this week in the campaign with
will ferrell and zach alfinakis will
ferrell plays a north carolina long
mini term
congressman and zach galfinakis plays
the kind of innocent stooge who's put up
against him in the race of course
there's mudslinging of course there's
hijinks and you know will ferrell can
play a politician as he did for many
years on snl
with a little bit of a
bushy and bent to him in this movie and
you know zach alfonacus can play the
cherubic idiot because he does that
basically for his livelihood
the one x factor here for me is director
jay roach who yeah has done a lot of uh
very lucrative comedies but in recent
years for me is kind of tailed off but
saving grace he's not working with mike
myers so i think we could be in for a
treat if you're into spy stuff excellent
go see born legacy i'm just going for a
change of pace here so it's the campaign
this weekend at a theater near you but
now let's talk about video games
now in in the pantheon
of classic or modern classic uh european
style board games
a lot of them have already come to ios
um carcassonne ticket to ride
dominion should be here soon but last
week ravensburg digital
finally brought to ios their adaptation
or their
official license of rio grande games san
juan
which is the card based version of the
game puerto rico
so san juan is now available and it is
eight dollars which yeah it's a little
pricey as all these board game
adaptations are but it's done flawlessly
it is a it is a card based game
with many phases in which you and your
opponents are all trying to
develop civilization through building
facilities and and producing goods and
selling and trading
and and doing it that way it's a lot of
games kind of work within this theme san
juan is a great one it's really well
done the music is there the the the card
artwork is official it's really well
done i've been i've been playing it a
lot since it came out last thursday so
highly recommend it even if you're not
into european style board games and
you're up for something a little more
there's a learning curve a lot of rules
to it it seems a little complicated at
first but it is a lot of fun and
might i say it you'll be hooked so give
it a shot hasta maniana back to you
okay thank you for that now television
august is is a weird time because the
new season hasn't started yet there's
just not a lot coming out this year what
changes is the olympics are on and so
nbc has tried to take advantage of the
fact that someone is actually watching
nbc of their own free will and they are
using the occasion of the olympics to
preview two of the new false sitcoms
that they have coming
one of these is a spectacular misstep
called animal practice stars justin kirk
who you might know from weeds it is
about a veterinarian who runs an animal
hospital and it is you know when you
watch a movie and people in the movie
are watching a terrible show
the show is as bad as those shows in the
movie like it is i recommend watching it
just to see how bad a sitcom can be
however there is a silver lining and
that silver lining is the other sitcom
that they are previewing it's called go
on
and it stars matthew perry
chandler from friends who had actually a
decent sitcom on abc last year called mr
sunshine kind of got nipped in the bud
but he's back with a uh it's kind of an
ensemble thing it's about a sports radio
guy who has to go into
group therapy for grief counseling but
the people in his group it's actually
there's a pretty good rhythm to this and
i really enjoyed the pilot it actually
it also has tyler james williams who
played chris on everybody hates chris
who's grown up a little bit and
is still pretty funny it's great
ensemble cast it's gonna as few faces
you've seen before and whose names i
just can't
ever remember but they're all in it so
you know that guy with the beard he's on
it that the asian woman that used she's
in it uh good ensemble cast with some
good ensemble players
this is the one that i think is actually
going to be watchable and i think has
some room to grow and go into good
places oh and john cho who i really
really like john cho was on the show
harold not kumar
so
go on not animal practices on nbc check
it out this week after the olympics but
that is it for the monitor as always
email us at the monitor at wired.com
maybe you have a project you think we
should talk about maybe
you just like the cut of our jib either
way let us know maybe you think we're
idiots that's fine too email us we can
take it we got thick hides here at the
monitor we'll be back next week with
more pop culture coverage but until then
inspirational catchphrase here